as soon as polls opened it became clear
people were turning out in large numbers
if they were worried after weeks of
social distancing they didn't seem to
show it I think they're doing it quite
safely I think they're taking
measurements they're doing it quite
right Koreans and people around the
world are equally concerned but we
shouldn't cancel we should hold
elections regardless two days of early
voting last week saw record numbers of
voters including coronavirus patients
able to vote in specially segregated
polling stations special arrangements
are also being made for the thousands of
South Koreans currently in
self-quarantine
to leave their homes and vote so long as
they're not showing symptoms at the end
of regular polling some stations are
being kept open just for them this
outbreak has changed the way candidates
campaign and what they're campaigning on
the issue of North Korea has been
significant in all elections until now
Taeyang ho used to be the North Korean
deputy ambassador in London until his
defection and has now won election in
South Korea's most affluent district
Gangnam everything is buried by the
Oviatt 19 outbreak and North Korean
issue national security issues are no
exceptions to this in a current
situation the leader of a minority
opposition party an cheol-soo a medical
doctor by training volunteered to help
out in the Daegu epicenter for two weeks
and his party's popularity has improved
and president moon jae-in was lagging in
the opinion polls with domestic scandals
and poor economic performance until his
handling of the outbreak which has been
widely viewed as a success I got more
interested in this election because of
coronavirus and I'm looking at how
politicians are responding to it no zero
coordinates on Oquendo erosion president
moon has handled the outbreak well I'll
vote accordingly
a majority of the electorate it seems
agreed this ballot giving moon's
governing Democratic Party a convincing
win and giving South Koreans a further
milestone in the long struggle back to
normal life rob mcbride al jazeera so